[Music]
a local educator is navigating students
not just through school but through life
for today's teacher appreciation week
story mary jane belliesa takes us to
mission high where helping students goes
beyond the classroom
it's a one of a kind school with a
one-of-a-kind teacher i've had this
passion for arts and i always had this
kind of dream to take everything that i
learned and take it to a school that
maybe didn't have the same access to the
arts so i actually started volunteering
with a community
program for at-risk youth and that's how
i found mission high school mission high
school supports students who are going
through recovery from substance abuse or
addiction it's a place for second
chances being a teenager is hard no
matter what situation you're in and
seeing that they can feel comfortable
and that you're building relationships
with them and that they trust me really
makes a difference because they've gone
through a lot and dallas johnston knows
she's helping improve lives through her
lessons from bringing
musicians in to do guitar classes
artists to come in and do drawings
spoken word poetry open mic nights
painting sculpting
it's really really cool to see the kids
find a healthy outlet and i'm hoping
that's what i can provide by bringing in
arts integration with over 20 years of
experience johnston is more than just a
teacher principal barbara collins says
she is a rock for her students just to
watch her process how to help them grow
not only as writers but as individuals
that believe in themselves academically
it's so beautiful you can't let one bad
day even one bad week
wipe out all the good you know it's like
you really have to focus on the
difference that you're making the
changes that you can make mary jean
bellassa live local now